没办法，
你不能真吐啊，
你不能每天晚上把他想象成别的明星才能混得过去。
我现在有个结婚对象，
我不喜欢他，
但是他很合适，
家里也很满意，
他条件也挺好的，
他喜欢你吗？
他很喜欢我，
今年多大了呀？
我30了，
96年的，
之前谈了几个对象，
谈过两个，
有谈到你自己特别喜欢的吗？
有，
那你特别喜欢的那个，
后来是因为什么分开了呀，
他可能不适合过日子那种，
他为啥不适合过日子呀，
这个说他可能会有主啊什么的，
那不就证明你眼光不靠谱吗？
你还是挺理性的，
没有跟那个你喜欢的人走入家庭，
然后这个人他追了我十年，
就现在这个人，
那你讨厌他吗？
不要亲易接触的话，
我没有那么讨厌，
亲密接触的话，
你就讨厌她，
排斥她是不是？
是的，
很排斥，
那就算别恶心自己，
也别害了别人，
让我想起来那个谢若琳节目里面有个角色，
就是她老公每天晚上钻她被窝的时候，
她都得吐，
她真的吐过，
她只有把她老公想象成于泽成，
她才能够进行的下去，
这叫生理排斥，
没法过其是我跟你说的这个，
你感觉就是生理排斥，
你特别讨厌她亲近你，
拉你的手，
抱你，
拉你的腰，
跟你要发生一点儿亲密的行为，
你特别讨厌，
特别排斥啊，
就别委屈自己，
但是我觉得他的条件应该是我能找的算很好的了吧，
那也没办法，
你不能真吐啊，
你不能每天晚上把它想象成别的明星才能混得过。
去，
他也是对我超级超级好的那种，
就是自己接受不了，
意思就是这种情况，
建议还是算了，
你一点碰过没有试过，
实在不喜欢，
实在讨厌他是吗？
他是有什么体味吗？
闻着有臭啊还是什么？
我跟他躺在一起好几天没有碰我，
还是我先主动的，
我想跟他试试，
我想看看我到底能不能接受他还很害怕，
很紧张的，
就整个人都发抖的那种，
他是以前没谈过恋爱吗？
对，
他没谈过，
他说这个期间一直在等我，
他多大了？
他跟我一样大的，
你试过了之后他是正常的吗？
是正常的，
试过以后我更烦了，
他就是很执着，
很酸酷，
那就别勉强自己了，
就是我这样进入婚姻也很难过下去，
他不是一朝一夕，
也不是一天两天，
我想到跟他几十年，
我有点恐惧，
那就别为难自己，
也别害了别人，
那就算了，
那就该过该做的努力咱都努力到位了，
尝试咱也尝试到位了，
很多东西它是基因里面自带的，
你们知道就是每个人的身体会散发一种不同的类似于这个词，
可能不精准啊，
就是我描述一下，
就是信息素这样的东西，
你知道吧，
每个人的身体都会散发这样的味道，
不同的这个味道有的人他能闻到，
有的人他闻不到，
有的人他可能闻到了，
但是自己没察觉，
有的人是两个人，
就是生理性喜欢碰一起就电光火食，
碰一起就电光火食，
但有的人他俩就是生理性排斥，
生理性排斥这个东西你很难。
用理性去对抗她，
很难用我们学到的礼仪廉耻去对抗她，
我不是上海有个我大学闺蜜嘛，
她已经生了3个了，
她跟她老公估计就是那种生理喜欢又怀上了，
你这以后出去的话，
人家问你有几个孩子，
你一说4个孩子，
所有人都得震惊，
因为你们家孩子出去了之后，
人家问他有几个兄弟姊妹，
说4个，
肯定觉得你家是亿万富豪，
就凭这一点的话，
都觉得你家条件差不到哪里去，
大概就这意思，
有的人和人之间，
他就是生理性的相互吸引喜欢，
有的人和人之间他就排斥，
那没办法，
就像刚才那个妹妹，
你说用理性，
用修养，
用很多东西去修正，
这个东西修正不了，
生理性喜欢就是喜欢，
生理性排斥讨厌，
那就根本没法在一起过日子了，
就这意思啊，
记得点赞关注哦。